[Music]
and a human scum news you [ __ ] scum
you submitted by neater Peter
cleanliness an abusive momager forced
her adopted kids to perform for their
popular YouTube channel what's wrong
with that
good what I call is a family that's a
family business we what I call that
instilling discipline commitment and
striving for calls is what I call it I
think it's important that it's adopted
yeah because it's like she constructed
this to just have children sleeves oh no
you're already a bad bin and then they
came into a family to become asleep she
basically built a circus yeah she
adopted seven kids seven seven that's
dumb in Arizona I heard some people a
dog just for pay Chinese yeah oh my god
your government assistance or something
like that yeah Quadra
yeah I could be cats don't they come in
your house and lie to you I really
figure out if you can do anything
there's a step-by-step posture and then
whoa yeah it's a crazy process but they
still do it because yeah thank you shout
out to the lady across my street from
back home named Celia she was a foster
mom and she was so [ __ ] cool dude and
she's still gonna watch you yep she was
so cool dude she was even okay in
elementary school I beat up one of her
foster kids and she was okay with it cuz
you little ass although so she was
probably like the foster kid he needed a
lot of love he'll give up but the little
redheaded [ __ ] [ __ ] that fool man he did
yeah well he also didn't have teeth
either so here we go that was his fault
huh yeah he probably was a prick though
I'm with you he was really really
[ __ ] me he had teeth before David
came along that's exactly what it was
[ __ ] that guy you still meaning me oh
well yeah so this popular youtube
channel called fantastic adventures they
they were very popular they had a lot of
subscribers a lot of views monthly views
and so they
would this mom apparently would abuse
these kids so badly that she would use
pepper spray what the [ __ ] what yep on
their face and even on their general
wait what is this lady Chinese no wait
her name is she looks like a [ __ ]
headhunter she's 48 years old so she a
rich doctor ass no damn she even looks
that if you're a kid wouldn't you be
terrified of that [ __ ] look crazy I
know so sad I'm scared of present adult
they report that once they so they got
this tip from her adult daughter
biological biological daughter what a
good girl read about this it's like all
over the news oh yeah I've seen this and
so the daughter she went to the police
station and reported all this abuse she
said the pepper spray she said that they
that she would withhold them from food
and water and they would she would lock
them in a closet restrict their bathroom
use why cuz they suck at performing well
it's like if they didn't want to be in
the videos or if they forgot their lines
lines yeah they forgot their lines she
would abuse them like this do we have
any videos of the children's
performances because they could be
really really good thank you oh let's
try to check that out I don't know I'm
probably now hopefully I mean the entire
channel of bachelors oh hey question
though she trying to Joe jams you I feel
I don't know how to feel about the
daughter writing out her mom I think
it's good it's a long rap huh so she has
two adult sons that are also being
accused but they're not rats well yeah
but that's why they're in jail what does
they arrive in the I don't know man
sorry all right like they is
so they face seven counts of failing to
report abuse of a minor the mom she
she's butthole you could get in trouble
for failing to reduce yeah dude I should
be in jail a lot now me - I never rat on
my mom's rock throw me in jail I don't
know it was a crime to be a to not be a
tattletale
yeah well it's the use of a minor
oh so that specific things well that's
what that's what that is seven counts
can harm robbery w of a minor has to be
abuse of a minor C okay so we should be
in jail if we didn't tell our parents
that's right could even beat me up
although I fear the victim you gets down
lies the abuse of the minor I was a
minor you were the victim yeah I saw in
the mirror
my mom beating my committed a crime up
like the hell wrong with you man oh yes
there's a mom she's booked for two
counts of molestation whoa mom she
trying to flood oh you tell me you guys
yes the mom apparently they're saying
that at one point she pinched the penis
of what a little [ __ ] in hers as a
punishment he bled toward his penis I'm
queasy
she thought she's [ __ ] up some kids
so one of the kids said I either get
beat with the hanger or belt or brush or
get pepper sprayed from head to toe can
she please be the pinata for like a
children's birthday party and every gets
a baseball bat with nails on yeah yo you
know what though
that's Jo when she she goes to prison
she's gonna get [ __ ] up yeah because
all these kids are under the age of 10 -
you could be on that there's a lot of
woman's in jail all those women in jail
they probably have kids of their own
yeah and they're gonna know about that
[ __ ] they're gonna beat the living
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of her she might be like
oh yeah
yes oh she also got seven counts of
child abuse five counts of unlawful
imprisonment and five counts of child
neglect because the cops when they went
to her home they found a kid in the
closet Oh wasn't locked but it was like
an unlocked closet and they were only
wearing a pull-up diaper and then all
the kids looked pale and malnourished
and dehydrated where there was this one
kid who drank
I forgot how I think it was like three
bottles of water like in less than 20
minutes like immediately yeah I was so
dehydrated and all that back up five
minutes later probably gonna have some
problems there was this other little
girl who she refused to eat potato chips
because she was scared that her mom
would smell on her breath dan I got
traumatized but she that lady looks like
she's potato chips all the time maybe
she got mad that her kids would eat her
chest was a hoarder I mean I know where
all the food went so those kids really
had no incentive to perform right this
time like a like if why would you do
that right you know she wanted more
potato chips
what was her channel like a family
general yeah it was all about the kids
and like they would go on these
fantastic adventures they had like eight
hundred thousand subscribers they
probably hate Disneyland eight hundred
thousand she did it all for you to be
butanol these kids for the money she
probably wanted views and money and and
you piece of [ __ ] people watch then but
you say that we are bad huh oh we don't
abuse anybody on this channel and then
we don't we do it on camera
we're transparent that's right
yeah these poor babies I'm just glad
that they're taken out of that home
right suckster adopted and they got
picked up by this foster lady or
whatever and then she has to go now they
have to go to another home I hope in the
next home is like loving and nice I know
in another YouTube channel that they
have kids and like they do kid videos
right and they had done a collaboration
with these kids two weeks before this
happened they didn't see anything wrong
see anything and they're like the mom is
being interviewed she's just crying
she's like I'm so sorry I didn't see
anything when you
here like I wish I saw any type of sign
but she probably trained them really
good yep
like a pimp does a hoe mm-hmm I'm happy
sad II do my [ __ ] like that mm-hmm
that's crazy tiger like whenever we put
the camera from him he doesn't want to
just smack sit with like all right bro
we're done yeah
he's a diva oh he's already at that
level huh
look at him mama can we like where the
paparazzi yeah
I have a picture camera hit the light
mutters and she showed me one once you
could just see him running up he runs
him across the room like we don't really
have Isaac that much in our videos
either cuz he just got over especially
knowing that his friends watch our
videos like yeah I'm so uncomfortable
and I could tell too like if we're
filming him he just kind of gets weird
so I'm like okay I won't film you
anymore like it's they have anime before
that too we also if we catch something
that was like oh maybe he might not want
this out there in the public will always
ask him first - and be like hey are you
cool with us you're doing it wrong your
channel would do so much better
yep yeah did you make them seeing recite
lions do waybut pepper spray is general
I better seem to find the cause of the
next time I come over noon hmm if he's
out there in this room I would be so
upset that's why they got a 800,000
subscribers oh my god
people are really dumb well also when
things like this come out it's it
destroys the trust between fans and the
reality of YouTube so I think like now
they're super skeptical of everything
even when people are being completely
genuine not JK news though I mean how
can you fake the debauch the [ __ ]
you know like you got to work really
hard they would you know to fabricate
what we're doing because it's like the
opposite it's too relaxed I know that's
why I've editor she says like no man
what we fabricate is toning it down
that's the problem you know we had to
cut out the [ __ ] that's like oh [ __ ] I
forgot the cameras on our on you know
you know the inside talk they're having
a genuine moment [ __ ] cut that [ __ ]
up part we're not acting loving to you
guys cut that [ __ ] out the way David
Miller rocking it's [ __ ] just [ __ ]
I think they don't realize that it is at
the end of the day entertainment so a
lot of things are either expressed a
little bit bigger or played up because
the camera doesn't translate that
emotion so like when people can do it
well they're like 10 times their energy
they're like hey guys what today we're
gonna [ __ ] do this and that's that
energy you have to do that because if
you speak like a normal human being it
doesn't go through well yeah it was
always like some weird calm it's just
like why are you getting angry I'm a
human being
[ __ ] go [ __ ] die I agree that's true
well I mean we do the same thing right
when we watch like athletic sports or
they become our little like avatars and
characters yeah and then you mean
politics celebrities like like someone
like Kim Kardashian like people were
constantly talking [ __ ] about her they
don't even know her but I like oh look
at that [ __ ] ugly [ __ ] or like I
can't believe she did this [ __ ] [ __ ] her
and it's like how come you have so much
negative emotions towards someone you
never met before I just want her to give
me money
[Music]